the president made a decision which is
consistent with his view
that this was not a winnable war uh to
bring the u.s troops
home some after 20 years of fighting
this war
we left our troops there our troops
would be at risk they're leaving behind
a country in conflict
with so much loss of life
with so much suffering at least we will
know who to blame then
when they're not here our troops may be
leaving but support for afghanistan
is not ending afghans are going to have
to decide their future what they
what they want what they want but it
won't be for the lack of us
being helped we're back with our panel
bill mcgearn columnist for the wall
street journal
charles lane opinion writer for the
washington post and jonah goldberg
editor-in-chief
of the dispatch so with those comments
in mind bill i want to start with you
part of their future appears to be
they're going to have to continue to
fight back the taliban which has been
once again advancing what do they do now
yeah well i think they're in a hard way
look one of the one of the
problems i think with the withdrawal is
that we're at a point now where it
doesn't require a massive
u.s troop presence but it requires
really firm air support and so forth
you know and i i think we're going to
see a very bad thing on september 11th
when
when this is completed just look at that
anniversary and we're gonna have
all this kind of triumphant stuff by the
taliban on that day
this has always been their argument that
america does not have the patience
that we they just had to wait us out uh
you know i look in in europe where we
had a presence for so many years
you know and i think it kept the peace
and i look into in asia where we also
have a presence you know in places like
korea
and i think it served its purpose and i
think we've
we've diminished our cap capabilities
for the region
with this decision jonah this has got to
be one of the most difficult
calculations that any administration
makes where so many american lives have
been invested
when is the right time to go
yeah i mean but look i think bill is
right the actual casualty rate in
afghanistan had been remarkably low by
this point
uh you know we've had troops in the
sinai for far longer than we've had
troops
in afghanistan and it's it's you know
the administration says they want to
move to a geostrategic
you know big power uh foreign policy
well having an air base and assets on
the ground
right at the intersection of russia and
china and pakistan
seemed like a good idea to me i was
against pulling out when donald trump
proposed it and i'm against
when joe biden wants to do it and i
think it's particularly
grotesque that would do it we're
planning on doing this on september 11th
which is the biggest
unforced pr gift we could possibly give
to the taliban and al qaeda
so charles we are keeping uh diplomatic
structures in place there will be a
small contingent of u.s troops to make
sure that those things are safe
so what's your take on our walking away
well i uh i think that this has been a
long time coming
president trump wanted to do it
president biden has wanted to do it for
a long time and
whether it's a good idea or not i think
it's going to be perceived in a lot of
the world
as a defeat for the united states and to
jonah's point
that there's a concern now with pivoting
to more great power competition well
great powers such as russia and china
will draw their own conclusions
about our staying power and our defense
commitments in places like korea and
taiwan and if it gets very ugly on the
ground in afghanistan and their
bloodbath and
vietnam 1975 type scenes it could have
domestic political repercussions as well
all right i want to go lightning round
truly lightning round on this next one
so we can get to your winners and losers
as well
but what about this conversation that
there's this group of bipartisan
senators who went to the white house
thought that they had hammered out a
deal
now it seems like there may be more
strings attached than they initially
thought
uh bill start with you does this group
get this framework
and you know as we understand it in its
infancy right now
does it get across the finish line
without something else attached no i
think they look i think they look like
chumps look at the journal we've argued
that this was
not a compromise from the beginning this
was not give and take
this was president biden taking what he
gave
in a bipartisan bill and then stuffing
it back in another bill
to get through and i think the
republicans have found that
the only argument ever for doing it was
to take the popular parts
infrastructure out of all the democratic
spending
and pass that to make another bill
harder but i don't think it's done that
and so the republicans have hurt
themselves a little bit with this but it
gives
mitch mcconnell a stronger place now to
make his stand
okay guys we're going to go to winners
and losers because i just want to make
sure that we get those in
charles i'll let you kick us off
on the infrastructure or winners and
losers no we're going to go to winners
and losers so we can give you guys your
chance at that
okay so my loser is rudy giuliani who
has had his law license
suspended in new york for his
inopportune comments on the
on the campaign trail and my winner of
the week is more of a kind of a
valedictory farewell winner is conan
o'brien who
sure he's losing his show but i think he
deserves a salute for
almost 30 years of really funny stuff on
tv
jonah okay so
my winner of the week
is and i'm trying to rob my winner of
the week are all of the ufo nerds who
finally have a great excuse not to have
a date this weekend
because they can finally read this
report from the government
and my loser of the week are the uh
are the minority represent diversity
committee
of the bailey beach club the sheldon
whitehouse beach club because because
of sheldon whitehouse's political hot
water that means they now have to have
their entire summer being a working
vacation
so they can start looking like a little
bit like america
all right will you close us out
okay winner of the week are the
journalists at apple daily
who fought the good fight until the
bitter end to keep their newspaper going
while the hong kong government was
trying to shut it down
loser of the week is bill de blasio and
all the other soft on crime democratic
mayors
in new york's mayoral primary democratic
voters chose former police officer eric
adam
a clear vote for law and order
yeah we await the final results of that
very interesting ranked voting which
we're all learning more about up there
in new york
all right panel thank you so much have a
great week